hello everyone and welcome to uh
hopefully a very nice uh Blitz game it's
a three minute Blitz game on leeches we
are playing against uh rudian and we're
gonna try and win a great game uh he
starts by playing the Scandinavian so it
might also be him who will be winning a
great game uh but we'll see uh we're
gonna try uh to play an interesting game
an active game uh get our Queen in we
don't want our Knight here to be
bothered too much uh
yeah let's go here
Castle
I would Castle King said usually but now
he's probably considering a queen side
Castle also so I want to have castles of
opposite sides want to make it uh as
interesting as possible
okay so let's move the queen here he's
probably gonna move the bishop to G6 so
let's go there let's go here
uh all right so yeah let's go for it
okay what he pre-moved that
I really thought we were gonna have some
fun here let's go here
it's not okay maybe we're playing a bit
too fast like uh you know like sort of
as if it were bullet but uh
you know now he does have the semi-openb
file to use for attacks I'm gonna I'm
gonna give this up like I have the two
Rooks I don't really want his Bishop to
come here and attack me
so yeah let's go here
once he captures I go H5
uh right I'm gonna try and make it uh as
active game as possible okay so now the
G file opens up
yeah let's go here threatening some very
very nasty discoveries now
obviously I has to play that
um what's the best way to continue this
um
yeah let's go no
can we play this
uh let's go no no no no no nope
I don't want to give up my D4 Pawn but
also it might be completely relevant to
the game
and I don't want okay so now the Knight
left the Knight left of the building
let's go threaten
dead Bishop on H7
okay he can take obviously play Queen A3
check I can just move
doesn't look like that big of a deal
let's play F4 F4 is always just
bothering me pretty much
I don't want it there yeah okay let's
Now we move
no we don't
he's very he's being very annoying here
and now we can threaten mate but also we
don't want to
it's quite quite the game
yeah
okay now Bishop captures yeah he should
have played Bishop captures like
completely messed it up if he played
Bishop captures then it's a three piece
I actually had no idea how to get out of
this one
all right so now we're we're really
trying to make this work and uh
obviously the reason for that is that it
doesn't work
uh
[Music]
uh yeah once he takes once he takes my
knight it's it's all over
okay so he even plays that
I don't know not taking my knight is
sort of allowing me to
to continue playing this game even
though it's lost uh
like my position is completely lost uh
allowing me to play it doesn't really
seem like like the way to go
uh but yeah he locked everything in so
nothing to be worried about here
obviously
it's very nice
here
all right
okay so he takes the pawn which is
probably good but then again the queen
has to be very careful otherwise I will
get a couple of moves in here let's go
here
he will take I don't care I'm gonna play
B4 B for wins every game uh
okay so now it's uh now it's a flag off
so
ah he found it he found it
hiding behind our Pawns
there we go we won that was terrible
that was pathetic uh I'm actually very
ashamed that this happened so I'm gonna
play another game
sorry about that
I I promise not to not the uh play as
poorly as I did in this one uh but no of
course uh I'm just joking my opponent
played a brilliant game and it's always
nice to congratulate your opponent so
congratulations on that uh but we're
gonna try and prevent our opponent from
playing such a great game this game
we're gonna play a little bit faster and
uh okay
so not not bad let's see what we have
here
uh okay let's go Queen B3
um let's go A3 trying to get him to
capture on C3 which of course he doesn't
want to
um
and okay
uh D4 is a little bit weak so we're
probably gonna get
[Music]
um
what's defend it
oh he wants to get another attacker over
to D4 which is fine I can even allow
this yeah I'm actually looking forward
to him capturing this
um yeah
so while my default Pawn is defended uh
the position itself isn't all that
impressive
yeah the Knight coming the C4 I don't
really think it's all that great
now it might be now it actually might be
as I do I do have E4 at some point I
should play yeah that's what I was
saying I should play uh King to H1 first
of course of course
it's a free night but what are you gonna
do
at least we have more time
I'm hoping he's gonna be a little bit
scared of 95 but or Knight G5 uh I don't
know
it's his time he's the one that has to
calculate
yeah he's not gonna allow it so
um
obviously obviously obviously we can
still defend it indirectly
with
with with with with what I have to trade
here
unfortunately
maybe I had something I don't know yeah
okay so we trade
so 95
has to defend the pawn
it's a really weird position really
weird position
uh he's up he's up to pawns I'm up a
minute so not bad
here's some background issues of course
he will solve that immediately now
um
so we'll see maybe not the best way to
go about it maybe keeping pieces on the
board was the way to go
but still yeah is there a way for him to
go for some sort of a modern mate I
don't think so
so yeah let's Okay so he just blundered
another piece that's sad
[Music]
for him
but of course I am very happy about that
okay let's go here and let's go
yeah let's go here
all right so let's Advance our Pawn the
victory
uh let's go here let's go here
let's go here of course I also want to
uh there we go I knew he was going to do
that wow this was also also just a
disgusting disgusting game
let's go let's go even
here
yeah this was oh he left all right so
we're gonna claim the victory wow that
was that was again absolutely disgusting
I'm very sorry for this we're gonna play
another one because this was disgusting
uh uh and I'm black now and D4 all right
let's play Super normal moves and let's
just okay I want to play a normal game
but he goes for the London I mean
what are you gonna do let's play Queen
B6
I even made a tutorial on this once uh
and you know you always get such
interesting positions with this
okay uh let's
let's go all in or all out E5
yeah there we go
there we go let's play Bishop captures
and we might even go for uh for a queen
side Castle to make it really uh just a
brutal brutal game
all right so he's going after the pawn
here we're not gonna allow that let's
just develop
uh this will be
a truly truly great way of
tackling the the London system
all right so he wants the queen side
Castle as well
so fine
[Music]
um
yeah let's go here
if he castles Queen side now then this
also becomes an issue
okay so he's not worried about that at
all
uh so I'm gonna go for it
yeah again really sorry about that
disgusting game uh in uh the first game
that I played also second one wasn't
much better uh what is this why is he
taking my dark Square Bishop like he
knows he will
suffer here so
okay
uh yeah I will take it I will take it
uh
what are the chances uh what are the
chances if I offer my queen he takes it
and I deliver Checkmate is it something
that he would be interested in let's try
it it I know it's it's a disgusting uh
way to play but I thought maybe you know
yeah okay he allows it I didn't play it
just for that I actually thought it was
a good move because it prevents the
advancement of the e-pawn as then the
bishop is hanging but since he allowed
it
fine uh but okay that's enough I'm
playing uh terrible chess I want to I I
will prepare better for the next one I
will check all of the games that I've
played here and I will analyze them here
you can also just analyze the games like
this so what was uh what was really the
problem here let's uh check this out
okay okay I've played B6 very nicely uh
okay this is all perfectly fine yeah
uh D5 and now E5 okay so this is still
playable okay but capturing here is the
the mistake that he made allowing this
was just giving me a bit too much
uh obviously did I uh have anything
better here
okay there were some improvements
obviously but no the entire game is
pretty much pretty much yeah just fine
here queen bee queen B5 still I mean uh
there are of course better moves like
you could make a developing move here
which is uh but even Queen B5 it's not
terrible I'm still completely winning so
there was uh you know an idea behind
this so uh again so sorry if if it was a
bit too much uh but yeah those were the
games hope you guys enjoyed it really
sorry about the that flagging in round
one but sometimes you have to resort to
that as well sometimes you know you play
well but it's just not your day and then
you have to resort to flagging so what
are you gonna do uh those were the games
hope you guys enjoyed it a bit of a
different scenery than we usually have
when we discuss Grand Master games but
this will also motivate me to improve as
well as I will go over the lines that
were just played and I will brush up on
them to be ready for the next one if you
guys enjoyed this I might even uh try
another one tomorrow maybe make it even
a daily occurrence so we'll see how it
goes uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh and uh yeah see you soon
in the next video